hello and welcome to zero playing RC
door off with black okay okay let's give
er give to Zurich will again I haven't
played this for a long time at least it
feels like that out of four games i only
have scored 2-2 draw against this guy
not very nice
yeah a little white can white bay
exchange on your five now or play D 5 D
5 is a bit more complex root ethically
but D takes d5 is of course very
playable
b3 ok so I'm ki could win the porn now
but he definitely has compensation yeah
we'll probably still check it I mean
it's a bit too difficult not to check
and so I take this where is the big
thing ok yes Bishop b2 or something but
well this is what it is probably
compensation but and is it much more
than that hmm doubtful yeah so what
happens here he doesn't have a direct
way here to to check this i believe may
be here i am rugby sevens rugby aid and
i have Queen situate so attacking be
three so in case of rookie one or so I
have Quincy to counter checking on the
queenside
yeah yeah a form comes into into
consideration yea my queen no Queen
doesn't have but again again I can do
this right a for rookie one Queen g-form
it's got rookie for then maybe but Queen
to g6 now it still looks playable rookie
one Quincy phone before I can take of
course nonsense rookie for can take the
Queen on g4 is actually covering a
covering g7 yeah so Queen g6 Queen g6
then he actually can play before hmm
maybe Here I am attacking I'm taking h3g
598 getting shaky but ok currently g5 I
can take so it's not yet coming
this is not so bad for him anyway I mean
maybe it's good for him but I think even
if I get to take yes ma'am even if I get
to take it like this he always has
played with his bishop so it's not a
sort bad for him anyway here it's got
two very strong bishops might be seven
ponies is under fire so this doesn't he
doesn't have much to worry about and he
can play on some I don't know 22 or so
it's so definitely air it's definitely a
move that he can that he can play Bishop
d7 is still on and yeah maybe it's is 6
and blunt oh wait i have six hangs on
the screen g5 okay
25 at this age six maybe not so
dangerous take stakes well it's a
dangerous position for me
Queen age six maybe just yeah this is
gota tweenage six I don't have a clear
wager to cover this look at this one
okay Queen to e7 or what no I don't know
well then I have king up how to play
okay six maybe this actually for King g7
it's a bit awkward to defend here all
the time and oh I didn't see that didn't
see that coming at all wow it's
embarrassing totally forgot about it
cool bad
come to play against a three but ok so
he wants to get pressure against my pawn
on the 7th cup ok come back soon look
137 I've got rooked e8 and my deep onus
is going look this sound probably look
28 hmm it's not threatening that much I
think
this is difficult time now that deep one
is quick very very quick any threats no
I don't see it so when it's let's do
this now if I promote your take I can
check and then promote right check check
time morning check is going to check on
each zone start to perpetuate verisign
snow potential right but now we resign
yeah I can I can I can take it back just
just run for the hills here that
shouldn't jack no that's not nothing
yeah I guess I defended that well even
though it was tough it was very tough I
mean taking that poem was definitely a
bit risky but I felt okay show me
White's compensation is very substantial
here with the two bishops and and all
the open lines Jim I mean this was just
very principle stuff I know it is better
here and it's better here the computer
gives white just a slight advantage but
it's um it's very awkward to play those
bishops are very strong yeah I felt I
should at least blunt one of them with
c6 take stakes and now I expected queen
age six and I wasn't even sure what I'm
going to do then he did this okay which
is probably also all right i mean here
yes i will have played for the porn in
any case it's just a question if you can
get an advantage or not yeah h6 was I
didn't I see this but I saw this but I
didn't see that b7
Thanks so this was the issue and now
he's definitely better here okay this up
to this point the engine agrees with
this play and says it's equal so
probably it was a relatively welded well
played game up to this point and Katie
form and now the engine gives sees draw
with the rook f7 check this is what the
engine wants to do oops and this
Japanese this and it says it gives the
draw here well anything can happen in a
blitz can but it's probably correct them
here here and this is probably risky
right yeah this is risky but now it's
difficult here queen bee successor
engines move to maybe get a draw like
this loop TX loop cheeks Jackie chicks
king chicks come you together black king
is to open it it's going to be some
perpetual guy guess so this is what he
did I know the deep one gets to be very
dangerous and greenback and he I'm
winning and yeah this was still
continuing the fight seems that I have
to do this yeah with the slightly better
ending due to the pawn it's difficult
still in terms of winning chances why it
has this activity IM not sure and this
this loop is right so I'm just
jan you know yeah so our first win
against mr. cedar off ok thanks for
watching